مساء الخير يا جماعه انا احمد فوزي 37 سنه
فخور اللي انا اتورت في اسكندريه وتربيت
فيها
ا دراستي كانت في كليه فيكتوريا وفي
ثانويه عامه كحلم الشعب المصري ان هو يخش
كليه ال هندسه للاسف ما
حصلش عدت ثانويه عامه تاني علشان اخش كليه
هندسه وبرده ما حصلش فدخلت تجاره انجليزي
تخرجت منها في سنه
2000 في سنه 2000 لما تخرجت منها انا ما
استنتش ان انا ادور على واسطه او اشتغل في
حاجه كبيره بدات في شركات
صغيره لاث اربع شركات لحد لما جت الفرصه
اللي انا في 2003 انضم لشركه ام سي جي
ملتي
ناشنال وم 2003 بدات اتحرك من ديبارتمنت
ديبارتمنت
واترقى فيها وفي 2007 اجوزت و 2008 ربنا
كرمني بنتي
تاليه في 2008 في اخر 2008 بدات احس ان
انا مش شايف السكرين قوي بدات اكبر
السكرين قعدت اكبر الاكين
من 2008
لحد نص
2010 في نص
2010 ترجمه ما بقتش
خلاص بقيت اركب التاكسي واقعد على حج حد
ادخل حمام الستات ود حمام
الرجاله فكرت في البيزنس فتحت برايفت زنس
في اخر 201 تاني يوم والدتي تت عمليه
القلب كانتو ب دخل كير الموضوع بقى
اسوا
وفيز بتاعتي في كواتر 2011 قالوا لي يا
فوزي ما تقلش انت معانا احنا عارفين ان
انت اشتغلت معانا كنت بتيجي 8 الصبح تمشي
اين بالليل في ايام كنت بتقعد لاث ايام
شغال من غير ما تروح فقالو لي احتى معانا
مهما حصل لما حد يقوللي حاجه زي
كده حاس ان انا كل يوم بروح الشغل ما
بعملش حاجه احساس تقيل على اي
حد ان هو يروح الشغل بياف مرتب من غير ما
يعمل اي
حاجه بدات احمد ربنا ان انا مادخلتش فييه
مندسه كان زماني ما بشتغلش برض خالص
بالمكنه ولا اي
حاجه بدات احط قدامي ايه اللي انا المفروض
اعمله مسؤول من
الاسره عندي مسؤوليه
لاهلي في واحد اعز اصحابي قاللي تعال فوزي
تروح القاهره في ترين سنترز للمكفوفين
بيعلموا حاجه اسمها جوز ان ي دي اي دي
حاجات من حبايب الم
الموفين بتقدر تقرا السكينز من غير ما
تشوفها وتقول لك كل حاجه المفروض الترين
ده كان لاث شهور الشركه قالتلي اوكي جو
رحت القاهره
وقعدت شهر بدل لاث شهور كنت بخلي
الترينر علاء ده من اعز الناس اللي عندي
ده تكليف تماما قلت له انا مش عايز ا لا
شهور انا عايز اعد شهر كان بيسهر معايا
عشان اقدر اخلص الموضوع ده وارجع لاسرتي
وعيلتي الكبيره اللي هي شركتي اللي هي
واقفت جنبي في اسوا فترات
حياتي لما رجعت تاني في اخر 2011 الشركه
وبدات اشتغل تاني بمون تور مقفول بطلع
ريبورتات بدات
الشكه وانبهر من ادا وبدات احسن كنت
بعملها
زمان اللي خلاني اعمل كده وال انا ماعدش
كل يوم من غير
ماتعلم وابدا اعوض الشه الشركه بتاعتي و
في الفتره قبل مااروح كنت حاطط قدامي لما
قال
انا عرفت 10000
طريق هيفشل فانا كده محظوظ انا عرفت 100
طريق مش هينجحوا كت حطط قدامي ديزني لما
اترفد من الجريده بتاعته
وبعديها عمل تيكون كبير
اس بعد سنه تقريبا من شغلي
وانا
بشتغل ق يا فوزي ايه رايك نعمل بروكت في
تنميه مستدامه للناس الموفين احنا بدانا
نصف ان الانسان الكف ذو الاحتياجات الخاصه
ممكن هو يق وينجز
شغله فع كذا فكره بس انا كنت حابب فكره
اللي هي سمتها مشروع
اراده بكل اختصار
شديد فريق
عمل مندع البصر او موفين تماما بيبيع
لقطاع معين في الشركه اللي هو قطاع
الصيدليات
منتجاتنا في الشركه من غير ما الصيد يعرف
ان اللي بيبيع ده واحد مابيشوفش بياخد منه
الاوردر اللي ممكن
تحصله حيث اسعار او اي اعتراضات بيعيه
ادربت الناس عليها ادربت على
شويه ادربت على ان هي ازاي تسجل على
السوفت وير اللي احنا عملناه يكو مع اللي
احنا
عملينها الناس قعدت تتمرن لاث شهور كنت
بادئ بفيل كبير جدا عشان قلتلهم يا جماعه
احنا هنبتدي 30 واحد هقلل هقلل اللي هيجوا
لايف معايا في اكتوبر 2 و واحد او اننين
بكتير علشان دور هيكونوا اشطر ناس ان هم
ينجحوا الفكره والشركه تؤمن بيه ونكبر
الناس
ا بدات بواحد في اسكندريه الواحد ده ما
كانش عندي ثقه تماما ان هو ممكن ينجح نجح
ولما نجح حسيت ان روحي راجعت لجسمي تاني
بقينا واحد انين لاه بقينا لاثه ممبرز من
اراده في باور في اسكندريه اوت اوف ثلاثه
فيتس ان شاء الله هنروح القاهره باذن الله
في 2015 بحلم ان انا اغطي 27 ديسبور يكون
فيهم 27 نزو الاحتياجات الخاصه المخوفين
المسج اللي انا عايز اقولها لو انت لقيت
حد في الشارع ما بيشوفش او نظره ضعيف حاول
تساعده وما تتخيلش ان هو انسان ما بيفكرش
لا هو بيفكر بيعرف يشتغل
كويس
الشركه كرمتني على مستوى الوب تيم كله كنت
واحد السنه دي من سبعه اكرموا على مستوى
العالم من 194 الف موظف في الشركه اللي
انا
فيها كان احساس جميل وباكد تاني ان اي
انسان ما بيشوفش او معاق او فاقد رجله او
عينه او
دراعه لازم تكمل الحياه طول ما في نفس
طالع وداخل وبقول لكم حاولوا تساعدوا
الناس حاولوا تعبروا عن حبكم لبعضكم لبعض
كل واحد يعبر لمامته لباباه لاخوه لاخته
لمراته
لبنته كل حاجه هو بيعملها لازم يقول لهم
انا بعملها عشان بحبكم وبتمنى لكم الخير
شكرا
جزيلا